aujourd'hui je vous parle d'un monstre
je vous parle de ce monstre là qui fait
pas moins de 3 kg 7 c'est l'alienware de
la marque dell area51 1er juin
j'appelle noire américaine avec l'accent
à quelque chose près c'est juste un
monstre je crois que c'est leur pc
portable de guémy le plus extrême que
j'ai jamais eue et quand je dis extrême
je pèse vraiment les mots vous allez
voir une config absolument incroyable et
la tue pas si vous rendez compte il y
avait quand même pour 4300 euros
c'est juste un truc qui est hallucinant
qu'on peut faire avec c'est démesuré
alors je vous lis tout de suite mais au
clair enfin si vous le savez si vous
avez l'habitude de me suivre je ne suis
pas gamer donc je n'ai pas l'habitude de
jouer à des jeux de dengue à aller
poussée des pc portables ou pc de bureau
dans les retranchements
c'est pas mon cas moi j'ai plutôt
monsieur tech donc je m'intéresse
beaucoup à l'attaqué et cet ordi il me
faisait de l'oeil pourquoi parce que
c'est une bête c'est vraiment un truc
hyper extrêmes on peut aller très loin
avec et je crois que pour le mettre à
genoux il en faudra alors cet alienware
area51 est super bien
il a aussi des points si peu négatif
tout content d'arriver une machine à
4000 euros on attend vraiment le top du
top on est quasiment au sommet il manque
pas grand chose
je vous explique tout le monde vous
allez voir c'est vraiment hallucinant
[Musique]
j'ai pas si vous en rendez courte mais
déjà la boîte
rien que ça ça vous met directement
parfum vous voyez la taille du truc
c'est c'est complètement démesuré je
sais pas si on peut parler d'ordinateurs
quand on arrive dans des bêtes comme ça
il est hyper hyper lourd il fait
quasiment 4 kg il fait 3 kg virgule 7
c'est vraiment une machine très très
lourde qui lorsque vous la télé comme ça
vous pouvez faire des haltères vous
faites des muscles ne la fait pas tomber
et pour 4000 euros là dedans donc bon
sac à main un petit peu dommage le
design est vraiment très typé c'est
futuriste je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais je vous a emmené il ya
quelques mois début d'année début
janvier aux crs à las vegas j'étais fier
la conférence de dell avec notamment
plaints de lancement produit notamment
cette machine là j'étais ensuite le vin
dans le showroom le rencontrer déjà j'ai
trouvé vraiment intéressante assez
hallucinant il y avait un nouveau parti
pris à une réécriture de la part de dell
en disant on continent gaming mais on va
toujours plus loin on apporte des
nouveautés et c'était vraiment vraiment
bluffant et la regarder ça là le design
de la machine en trouver les codes
alienware vous l'avez bien à 51 eur vous
retrouver là ce n'est pas du pastis 51
ceux qui se poseraient la question
attention l'abus d'alcool est dangereux
pour la santé
déconnez pas avec ça mais on a vraiment
tout hyper race et regarder à l'arrière
là le design que vous avez avec ses
grilles pour la ventilation il faut le
refroidir un franchement il faut c'est
hallucinant sur le côté on va regarder
la connectique dans quelques instants
la machine est juste complètement dingue
sur le dessous est également regardé
mois ses aérations en alvéoles en nid
d'abeille
c'est vraiment complètement ouf et
lorsque vous allez venir l'ouvrir c'est
là où la machine pour up
il faut vraiment faire gaffe quand toute
son ampleur la taille du clavier
le rétroéclairage vraiment rétro
éclairage ici on peut me dire
complètement le le personnaliser pour
avoir les couilles votre équipe ou
faites comme vous voulez c'est une
machine qui est vraiment hyper bluffante
chaleur on est un milieu de cette
machine là qui accroché à mon mur on est
vraiment sur une config absolument
hallucinante
on est sur un intel core i9 de neuvième
génération vous pouvez la voir en 7 mais
c'est vrai que lorsque vous voulez une
machine surpuissante le19 vous vous
surpassez tout vous avez 32 gigas de ram
ddr 4 po n'était jusqu'à 64 giga de ram
si vous êtes vraiment nerveux ou
nerveuse
la caméra fixe et une nvidia geforce rtx
20 80 avec 8 gigas de ram gddr5
didier et c'est une machine qui
refroidit grâce à la technologie
alienware crio tech enfin c'est en tout
cas c'est hallucinant vous avez double
entrée d'air double sortie d'air vous
êtes plein de trucs de tous les côtés
enfin je rentre pas vraiment dans les
tailles mais c'est extrêmement
hallucinant et surtout sur des machines
comme ça entendre et à voir un truc qui
fait du bruit avec des ventilateurs qui
tournent tous les côtés il n'y a
absolument pas c'est magique et
extrêmement silencieuses tout ce que de
ce point de vue là une très belle
maîtrise de la part de dell alienware là
dessus pourquoi est ce vraiment une
machine extrêmement silencieuse on a un
châssis en alliage de magnésium pourtant
se dire et magnésium si assez léger mais
vu les composants qui est derrière cette
machine ça me donne un ordinateur qui
malgré tout reste quand même très très
très très lourd faut il y en a des
petits bords qui sont quand même assez
léger votre petite webcam on a bien le
design avec alien vers la retrouve
effectivement la petite tête de l'alien
qui est situé juste ici pour l'instant
dans l'école d'alienware qui est
vraiment très très très très joli vous
avez un pavé ici tactile qui
complètement être clair je vous montrais
la question de du rétroéclairage du
clavier c'est vraiment bluffant mais
surtout et c'est peut-être le point de
regret que si cette machine vous avez un
écran de 17,3 pouces ça c'est bien
séduit psl céder sa marque se pose
absolument aucun problème par contre
vraiment point de regret sur la
résolution 1920 par 1080
c'est uniquement du full hd c max une
machine comme ça avec une nvidia geforce
rtx 20 80 on pourrait s'attendre à mieux
on pourra aller jusqu'à 4 kg à on
pourrait avoir une meilleure résolution
et c'est vrai que sur un ordinateur à
4000 euros
ça toujours un peu dommage d'être
uniquement sur du full hd ne serait-ce
qu'au niveau de la performance de la
machine on va voir de la fluidité
on va voir la fluidité cas super taux de
rafraîchissement de 144 m
ça c'est vachement bien au niveau de
l'écran mais ce qui manque c'est
effectivement une résolution meilleur
plus élevé j'espère qu'en 2020 à des
nouvelles va aller un peu plus loin nous
propose effectivement en écran 4cast
sort est vraiment un sens et la peau
qu'on doit quasiment la machine réelle
mais dans le vrai gros point négatif de
cette machine c'est son autonomie diane
tient pas énormément
dell nous annoncent trois heures ce qui
est déjà pas beaucoup en fait on est un
peu moins trois jours de suite entre
deux heures à 3 heures et ça c'est assez
problématique de toute façon cette
machine vu le poids qu'elle fait vous
n'avez pas globalement l'emmener avec
vous souvent parce qu'il est très lourd
donc même si on est sur un pc portable
on est en fait plus sur un ordinateur
gaming de bureau qu'on peut déplacer
mais qu'on va pas particulièrement
déplacée parce que pour recharger en
tenue s'extrait moment compliqué ça
c'est les blocs de charge vous avez 2
blog de charges monstrueux combien le
brancher un seul ne suffirait pas vous
avez un premier bloc de 330 watts qui
est juste énorme qui pèse 1 kg 5 rega
lui seul et vous avez un deuxième bloc
de 180 watts vous devez les branches et
tous les deux pour votre machine tienne
ça vous fait 510 watts et quand même et
non d'un côté derrière il faut
l'alimenter
mais si vous le faites pas assez
rapidement mais votre machine elle se
met en carafe
elle va manquer d'énergie et ça sera
fini pour votre session de jeu donc il
faut toujours en gros la voir branché
etc je trouve un petit peu le point de
regret est ce qui fait que cet
ordinateur du coup n'est pas un pc
portable nomade c'est un pc portable de
bureau pour pouvoir déplacer d'un
endroit à l'autre mais dans tous les cas
il faudra brancher il le faut donc
libérer deux prises pour venir
la branche et une et deux et comme ça je
peux brancher mon pc vous devez brancher
ici derrière mais regardez-moi la taille
de site blida vous brancher un et vous
venez up s'il veut bien venir
branchez le deuxième là et là c'est bon
vous êtes prêts pour repartir c'est vrai
comme ça on les met quand même assez
rapidement c'est pas hyper pratique
voyez d'avoir ça ça et de la voir comme
ça ça enlève un petit peu le côté
portable du pc à côté de ça la
connectique est plutôt bien fourni
vous avez si votre prise casque votre
prise micro de l'usb3 ici une prise
thunderbolt usb c'est du hdmi 2.0 on
importe sortie mini display prise rj45 à
2 5 gigabits par seconde pendant plus
efficace heures graphique alienware est
ici de quoi brancher vos deux
alimentations et sur le côté on va
retrouver encore ici de l'usb 3 points 1
vous pouvez venir complètement
l'overclocker ya différents profils
d'overclock peut aussi venir créer votre
nouveau profil pour régler ce que vous
voulez comme vous voulez que ce soit au
niveau cpu au niveau de votre carte
graphique au niveau de la ram vous
faites exactement comme vous voulez je
trouve que le clavier est aussi hyper
agréable on une course qui pas trop
longue il est hyper confort et en plus
un clavier qui est personnalisable vous
avez des touches prévenir personnalisé
sur le côté vous avez également des
touches ici au niveau du pavé numérique
alors ça clavier qui est quand même
assez grand vous avez si votre book
en plus sur le dessus pour venir
l'allumé pour l'éteindre le pavé tactile
est aussi vraiment très sympa qu'on n'a
pour moi un rendu qui est vraiment hyper
cali là dessus ce qui est vraiment bien
si vous pouvez me dire complètement
personnalisée les couleurs dans votre
logiciel au clavier c'est alienware tac
x éclairage led rvb rétro éclairé qui
est vraiment très bien et en plus
complètement personnalisable donc en
fonction des équipes en fonction de ce
que vous allez faire comme de ce que
vous allez vouloir si vous êtes dans une
équipe ou une autre vous allez pouvoir
mettre vos couleurs terre comme vous
voulez je trouve ça vraiment hyper cool
le personnalisez vous allez ici dans fx
et là vous allez avoir différents thèmes
vous allez pouvoir créer vos thèmes
comme vous voulez changer la couleur du
bouton ici vous voulez naviguer vous le
mettez comme vous voulez dans les
couleurs que vous voulez vous faites
exactement ce que vous voulez vous
pouvez régler ici les paramètres à
l'arrière de votre machine vous pouvez
venir régler aussi votre pavé tactile en
verre en rouge si vous voulez un pavé
tactile move si vous le voulez bleus si
vous le voulez la couleur vous voulez
vous faites toutes les couleurs de l'arc
en ciel
si vous qui choisissez et ça franchement
je sois vraiment hyper sympa on peut
venir tout personnaliser et ça c'est
vrai que c'est chouette
bien évidemment vous avez du bluetooth
5.0 et en plus vous avez du wifi jusqu'à
1,7 gigabits par seconde et bientôt qui
est vraiment impressionnant avec cette
machine cl eye-tracking bien le suivi de
votre garde dès lors vous l'acceptez
l'ordinateur sera exactement où est ce
que vous allez poser vos yeux et c'est
complètement là pour optimiser votre
expérience de jeu avec les jeux
compatibles
le truc est complètement bluffant donc
je n'achète pas le temps de regarder
l'écran je regarde vraiment ma caméra
histoire qu'on reparte pas et là j'ai
tout de suite posé mon regard sera
l'endroit en haut à gauche où il écrit
my toby vous êtes prêt e up on y va donc
là je regarde night au biel âge et mon
visage voiliers qui vraiment reconnu au
milieu up en bas à droite étalonnage
aurélien lacroix je regarde ma tobia
gauche
si on regarde je diffusais améliorer
expérience le visage en bas à droite la
croix voyez est truqué qui souffre c'est
vraiment la clinique des yeux pineuilh
sans mes yeux trouvent les yeux imaginez
vous êtes sur un jeu et bien vous
regardez un endroit plutôt qu'un autre
grand direct on le saura pourra vraiment
venir modifier des choses s'il est très
réactif ça va super vite c'est à la fois
très bien ça peut apporter beaucoup
d'expérience cas de le dire je regarde
expérience et ça peut aussi des fois
être un petit peu un petit peu
surprenant ça pourrait faire peur si
c'est mal utilisé côté stockage j'ai
intérêt à en rédiger deux disques de 72
sd ça marche vraiment bien ce qui ouvre
avec cette machine si vous voulez c'est
que dès lors que vous l'allumez vous
faites quelque chose vous installer un
programme
ça va extrêmement vite c'est très
réactif d'un côté avec tout cela
derrière c'est normal on a donc ses
avantages là on a aussi les
inconvénients derrière avec une batterie
qui du coup va pas être extraordinaire
même si effectivement sur le papier ça
plutôt bien
il faut la changer les blocs de charges
sont énormes l'ordinateur pèse lourd pas
là il a des gros gros avantage il ya
aussi des inconvénients qui sont non
négligeables mais malgré tout ce qui est
vraiment génial c'est l'avancé on voit
la puissance nous à son ordinateur
portable de gaming ce vraiment hyper
impressionnant et en termes de prix
c'est un ordi qui coûte tout là-dessus
4349 euros 50 dans cette config là vous
pouvez le prendre avec une config un peu
moins élevé avec un intel core i7 et
compagnie ça sera - cham est évidemment
de savoir si vous voulez le top du top
du top sur un pc portable à ce prix là
c'est tout de suite assez onéreux ça
c'est aussi un peu le côté négatif
à côté de ça c'est une excellente
machine qui est vraiment cool pour
notable de performance là dessus c'est
absolument pas du tout limitative pour y
aller fermer ce que vous voulez
la seule élite c'est la résolution de
l'écran les jeux vous voulez y'a pas de
soucis vous maîtres de l'averse faudra
super bien c'est pour moi une super
machine
moi j'aime beaucoup je sens vraiment
très bien ça va vraiment dans le bon
sens et d'un point de vue purement
technologique soit par l expérience de
jeu je vous sens vraiment bien je sais
pas vous dîtes moi est ce que vous êtes
joueur que vous êtes joueuses est ce que
la chine comme ça peut vous intéresser
ce que vous jouez sur alienware d'elle
qu'est ce que vous en pensez qu est ce
que vous pensez d'une telle bécane avec
la puissance qu'elle a avec le la
performance qu'à l'arrière
est ce que ça vous parle qu'est ce que
vous pensez bien évidemment des
avantages en termes de performances en
termes de refroidissement du fait ce
match ils sont vraiment pas du tout
bruyante mais aussi côté un peu plus
limitative du fait d'avoir un écran
uniquement en full hd et le fait d'avoir
quelque chose qu'on peut pas déplacer
extrêmement facilement son devoir
brancher dites moi ce que vous pensez
tout ça en bas en commentaire moi je
trouve ça en tout cas à ses coups et je
vous invite donc un essai un joli poussé
bien évidemment à vous abonner parce
qu'on parle d'ordi de pc gaming comme ça
mais beaucoup de plein d'autres produits
de teck
il ya plein de nouveautés qui vont
arriver d'ici très peu de temps je vous
embrasse et je vous dis à demain
bisous châu